a student learns that ionic compounds
have significant covalent character when
a cation has a polarizing effect on a
large anion so what are they talking
about so if i have a cation
so this is my cation and then this is my
large anion
my large anion right over here and
actually let me do it this way let me
make it a little bit clearer because a
cation still has electrons
so you have your nucleus here
of your cation you have your electron
cloud
you have your electron cloud of your
cation
right over here
but you have fewer electrons than you
have protons so you're going to have a
positive charge and that's why we call
it a cation
and
the anion
it still has a positive nucleus
it has an electron cloud i'm drawing a
large anion here
a
large a large
a large
anion right over here that's electric
electron cloud but it has more electrons
in the cloud than it has protons in the
nucleus so it has a negative charge that
is the anion and what they're saying is
is you start to have significant
covalent character remember covalent
bonds or electrons are essentially
shared between two atoms when a cation
has a polarizing effect on a large anion
so one one way to think about it is
these electrons that are out here
well they're going to want to get away
from all their elec negative friends
here negative charges repel each other
and they might want to spend close more
time closer to
this cation and so they're going to
start having covalent character they're
going to be more and more shared between
the two and there really is a spectrum
between ionic bounds and covalent bonds
and over here you might have a
polarizing effect these things spend
more time on the left hand side the way
i've drawn it than on the right hand
side so you're going to have more of the
electrons and more of the negative
charge hang out over here than on the
right that's what they're talking about
and as a result the student hypothesizes
that salts composed of small cations and
large anions should have relatively low
melting points all right
so it should be easy to take less energy
to break them out of their lat they're
kind of the salt lattice structure when
they're in solid form
select two compounds from the table and
explain how the data supports the
student's hypothesis let's see these are
all salts here and they're on on the if
the if these were to disassociate or if
you think about what the the cations
would be the cations
the cations
that make up
that make up these
these compounds you have lithium
lithium
you have
sodium
and you have
potassium and then the anions
the anions that make up
these compounds you have iodide
you have iodide and you have fluoride
so let me write this way fluoride
and
iodide so which of these are small and
which of these are big
well let's compare lithium let's compare
lithium sodium and potassium
and we see lithium sodium and potassium
they're all group one elements and in
general as we go down a group as we go
down a column in the periodic table
we're adding shells and so size
increases
so size increases as we go down like
this
size
size
increases
and so of these lithium is the smallest
and potassium is the largest of these
three
so lithium let me write that down
lithium is the smallest
smallest
and potassium is the largest of these of
these three
now if you look at the anions
well you have
once again fluorine and iodine are in
the same are in the same group and
iodine is below it it has way more
electrons and you've added way more
shells here this is actually the
important part and so you can see that
since iodine is larger than fluorine
well iodide which is either which is
when they gain an electron it's going to
be larger than fluoride
so iodide
iodide this one is larger
and the fluorine is smaller
so let's see lithium iodide is a case of
small cation
small cation and large
and large anion
and so that's actually the the direction
that's kind of the best example of small
of what the student is talking about
small cation and large anion lithium
iodide lithium iodide is a great example
of that and as we can see it has the
lowest melting point of everyone on the
table now let's take the other extreme
what happens if we take a large cation
and a small
anion well let's see they don't they
don't they don't have that combination
here
but let's see if we hold if this is
sodium well sodium fluorosodium fluoride
yes so sodium fluoride is interesting
because we have a larger
we have a larger cation
so this is a larger
cation and then we have a smaller anion
smaller
anion and notice that has the highest
that has the highest melting point and
so these are two that are good to
compare so part a i'm doing that blue
compare
compare
lithium iodide
which
has
small
small
cation
plus
large anion
to
to
sodium fluoride
which
has
larger
cation
plus smaller anion smaller
smaller anion
and we see
and
we see
that
their melting points
their melting points
melting points
consistent with hypothesis
consistent
with
hypothesis
the small cation
or
lithium
iodide so small i'll just write melting
point
melting
point
lower
lower and actually much lower
than
sodium fluorides
sodium fluoride
melting
melting point so at least if you compare
those two and they still seem to be good
extremes we took the lowest melting
point which completely typified what the
student was saying is having a low
melting point and we looked at the
highest melting point which had a larger
cation and a smaller anion and so just
looking at that it seems to be
consistent with the student's hypothesis
all right part b
identify a compound from the table that
can be dissolved in water to produce a
basic solution
write the net ionic equation for the
reaction that occurs to cause the
solution to be basic
all right so let's think about how we
can form a basic solution so essentially
we would need to nab some hydrogens from
the water molecules in order to have
some hydroxide laying around
and so there's a couple of candidates
here that could do that you have all of
these all of these halides you have the
iodide you have the fluoride and the
important thing to recognize is that
hydrogen iodide and you don't see or
hydrochloric acid since we're dissolving
it in water now hydro
it's not hydrochloric hydroiodic acid is
a strong acid
so
let's see
h
i hydro iodic acid strong acid
strong
acid
while
hydrofluoric acid
is a weaker acid
is a
weaker
acid so a strong acid is not going to be
good at nabbing hydrogens in fact it's a
strong acid it wants to give away its
hydrogens really really really badly
so so this so the the iodine does not
seem like a good candidate the floor the
the or the iodide the fluoride does seem
like an interesting candidate so let's
let's take one of these
let's take one of these candidates out
here you could use either the lithium
fluoride or the sodium fluoride let's
just take i know we've already dealt
with the sodium fluoride so let's just
keep using that so if you take sodium
fluoride
sodium fluoride
and so let me since we're they want us
they say write the net ionic equation
for the reaction that occurs to cause
the solution to be basic so we're going
to focus on sodium fluoride
sodium
sodium fluoride is what we select
we select sodium fluoride that's that's
the part the first part we identified a
compound that can be dissolved in water
to produce a basic solution
we select that and now let's draw let's
do first the ionic equation then we'll
do the net ionic equation so if you
dissolve this in water you're going to
have
sodium cations
dissolved in our aqueous solution plus
fluoride anions dissolved in our
dissolved in our aqueous dissolved in
our aqueous solution
and it is going to be
in equilibrium
in equilibrium
with
actually let me draw it
let me draw it this way
let me draw this way plus
plus
h2o because that's what it's going to
react with and obviously i don't have to
say it's an aqueous solution it it is
the aqueous solution so it's making the
solution aqueous this is going to be an
equilibrium with and i'll go to the next
row here if i was actually taking the ap
test well actually let me just
let me just copy and paste it here just
so we don't have to
deal with it on two rows so
put it right over there
so that
is going to be in
that is going to be
in
equilibrium
get the right tool out
that is going to be in equilibrium
with this this fluoride nabbing a
hydrogen
so
hydrofluoric acid we could say
h
hf
in our aqueous solution
plus
o h minus
in our aqueous solution and then you
still have
the sodium cation in our
aqueous solution and so this is you can
see you're going to perform at
equilibrium and so you're going to have
more hydroxide around so you're forming
your basic you're forming your basic
solution
if this was an iodide right over here
then this reaction would go strongly in
that direction if this was hydrogen
iodide right over here this wouldn't be
some kind of nice equilibrium this would
be a strong acid would go strongly it
would definitely want to get rid of its
hydrogens so that's why we don't want to
use hydrogen iodide we want to use
hydrogen fluoride you put in water
becomes hydrofluoric it it's it's likely
to donate it
we when it's in its gaseous form or it's
by itself we would call it a hydrogen
fluoride but now when we put it in a
solution we can consider it to be
hydrofluoric acid and so if you want
your net ionic equation well we don't
have to worry too much about these
sodiums they're on both sides of this
and so if you just focus on this right
over here this is
your net
ionic
net ionic equation